Film Courage: [Answering the livestream
comments] Sengaari, hello, another great
question “Why write and try to get my
work out there if the chances of it
being optioned or even read is extremely slim
in the real world?” Well that's a good question
Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: I’ve
got the answer to that because you're right,
it may never get out there, it might not be
optioned, it might not get out but what I've
learned through tons of failures and a couple of
kind of successes, is to embrace the process. Not
only embrace the process, just realize that you're
a writer, so you wake up every day as a writer. I
had someone ask me they're like “Oh how do you
get your inspiration?” I'm like “Inspiration,
what? No, I just write.” I have a routine, I
have these three structural things that I do
and then I get to my work and it's just I do it
every day. The beauty of that is the process,
nobody can take the process of writing away
from you, so you just keep crafting story,
crafting story, and even when good things happen
like when we had our premiere of Confessions of
a Teenage Jesus Jerk [Tony’s novel and adapted
film] and I got to do the Q&A and it was just
it was such an uplifting point and then the
next day I was depressed. I was like “Well
that's the end of that” but I learned a valuable
lesson, it's not the end of that. Tomorrow I get
to work on the other thing, I'm working on the
next thing. More important than the outcome is
the process and you have to love the process. You
have to love storytelling, if it's your religion,
you're going to show up every day to it whether
there's an outcome or not. It’s like playing the
lottery you’ve got to be in it to win it right
so in order to write in order to have stuff to to
show people you have to have a lot of writing
to show people that's finished and that and
you may be put in a good position more often
than not where people go oh send me what you
have and if you have a lot of stuff because
you've been working hard for a long time you
have things to show them and that's where the
doors open when there's things to show them I
hope that helps your question but the real
world is being at your desk writing every
day which is such a luxury and a cool thing
to do in life I it's my favorite thing to do.
Film Courage: And you write in coffee
shops a lot too, don't you Tony?
Tony: Yeah I do a lot of handwriting in coffee
shops. I'm the guy that never brings a laptop
and I also really hate doing and we're in Los
Angeles so I hate writing screenplays in coffee
shops. I write novels in coffee shops and then
if I'm working on a screenplay I'll handwrite the
screenplay at a coffee shop on a yellow pad and
then bring it home home and type it in. That's my
own weird quirk but yeah I just love the long hand
and then I print out I go home type it keyboard it
all in print it all out then bring the print
out the next day and sometimes the print out
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and before you
know it I have a binder that I'm doing rewrites
on and it's so whatever project that's happening
early stages is yellow pads later stage stages is
binder oh and going back to what sari is saying
did anybody say the same thing to you like hey
Tony that there's so little chances of this why do
it why waste your time with this well well I mean
I kind of grew up in a religion where you weren't
supposed to do anything but you know preach so I
so that's a little weird I was doing something
that was so not what you were supposed to do
so I had to fight through that people making fun
of me for writing and trying to write sometimes
that's good because sometimes I feel like people
should tease people a little bit to see if the
resolve is there and if you can get past those
people going you can't write what do you do what
do you think you are you're writing what do you
you're out of your mind you can't be a writer
and then you get past them then and it's almost
like that you walked through that first obstacle
you had the conflict you walked through your own
first obstacle and you're like I'm writing Lort,
hello from Britain. I'm writing my first TV series
I'm halfway through episode three of about six and
I'm really losing motivation to write oh that's
a good question how do you self-motivate during
moments of self-doubt thank you yeah I lose
interest too in stuff that's a great question I
love this question so all this question says to me
is you're a writer it's we the getting through the
self motivation and getting through the self-doubt
is what writers do to get to their end and that's
why people find it so hard to write because you're
going to hit that wall and it's almost like you
just got to show up with that self-doubt one thing
I try to do I'll work on a different project if
I'm having a really hard time with a current like
if I'm halfway through a a project I'll do some
short little writing thing that may never ever
get published or maybe even write outside of what
with those characters of something else just to
kind of bring some freshness back to it and then
just and then you got to come back in and just
feel like an impostor and feel like there's just
no way you're going to do anything right but you
continue to just plug away and ask questions well
where would it where does this go here and I'll
even write the questions I'll just be like I'll
have my characters ask me questions I'll write
their questions down and then I try to answer to
them and that has gotten me out of some some stuck
places as well so it's just I what your question
just proves you're a writer so and prove it even
more to get to episode 6 with all that self-doubt
and that hard motivation to sit down with it
every day I love that and you know sometimes
it seems like if things are messy around us maybe
it's time to just kind of like clean them up and
then make sure everything is like within its place
and we can kind of get a new spark again I don't
know that's yeah that's declutter right that's
the Marine there's declutter and then there's
repainting to avoid oh okay so then some of it
might be avoidance all right maybe I'm giving bad
advice no you're not that's actually no that is
something to shake it up we would that that would
I would think that's shaking up our environment
you know shake up the environment even more and
go to a park and right for a while and see if that
you know works it may not work may be a very bad
idea and is that what helps you being in coffee
shops because it's such a different environment
every day yeah and I plus people irritate me so
in coffee shops I get a little irritated and then
that I don't know what it is and I never really
put my finger on the why but it just and it's I
think I need to be vaguely irritated in order to
be self-motivated interesting which is kind of
great in I like that society because you could you
be irritated with anything sure sure especially
LA is very crowded yeah yeah yeah yeah V Martin
hello from Deep South Texas when did you realize
slash accept oh I like that accept that you were a
writer did you have the conflict deciding between
the artistic life and being a quote “normie” okay
well I got an answer we had this we actually had
this conversation before we started started y
I have an answer to that question I used to be
an normie I'm still kind of I'm still kind of a
normie I read and I may have said this actually
when we interviewed before but there's a book
by Knut Hamsun called Hunger and I read that
and I've been reading for a while but I've been
working also in like tech and things like that and
also doing like college radio I was kind of like
floundering around and when I read that I realized
oh man I’ve got to write and that's when I quit my
tech job and started because the tech job was fun
but it was life consuming so instead of doing tech
I just went and did temp work and was a file clerk
or whatever so I can just leave it at work and
come home and write and that's when I that's when
I decided that that I'm going to be a writer till
the death and and it was a very poor decision and
I should have stayed in tech financially now for
soul for for my soul it was everything I needed to
do and so I feel very lucky and yeah so just just
see just see if you need to tell your stories not
everyone needs to tell their stories for me I need
to tell my stories it's urgent when when I wake up
in the morning that I have stories in progress and
I am so happy that that's my life was there was it
building up to many years of you deciding to leave
the tech industry or was it a fast exit it's the
kind of it was I was in it for about two two and a
half years it was pretty fast and I just realized
it wasn't me I do love and that here's the I love
solving problems I love puzzles and you can do
that in tech and you can also do that in writing
because in writing all we're doing is when on our
first draft we're creating problems we we're just
creating huge problems for ourselves that we need
to fix almost like if we were debugging software
we need to debug our our our writing to make it
better and continue to work on the puzzle which
is how do I make this as perfect as I can make it.